خبر عاجل ومهم ا من واشنطن بوس عن مسؤول
بالمقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق الخبر يقول
نعلن مسؤوليتنا عن الهجوم الذي استهدف
القوات الامريكيه اذا حسب هذا الخبر
العاجل عرف المصدر ونقلته واشنطن بوس عن
مسؤول بالمقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق يقول
نعلن مسؤوليتنا عن الهجوم الذي استهدف
القوات الامريكيه اي سيد مايكل مولوي ما
هو
تعليقك نعم رايت هذا الاعلان قبل دقائق
قليله وهذا متوقع في حقيقه الامر بعده طرق
لانه المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق كانت
مستمره في استهداف القوات الامريكيه في
العراق وسوريا وهي لا تقوم بذلك عندما
يكون هنالك وقف لاطلاق النار وقد استمروا
استهدافات بشكل يومي في ما عدا فتره وقف
اطلاق النار
بالتالي ربط هذه الامور بما يحدث في غزه
والبحر الاحمر امر منطقي في حقيقه
الامر كان هنالك صله واضحه بين الازمه في
غزه وايضا بين القضايا الاقليميه الاكبر
واعتقد انها مصممه لضغط على الرئيس بايدن
من اجل ان يضغط على اسرائيل لتوصل لوقف
لاطلاق النار ايضا الخبر يقول ونقلا عن
مسؤول بالمقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق يقول
الخبر اذا استمرت الولايات المتحده في دعم
اسرائيل سيكون هناك
تصعيد هل هل تعتقد بان الاداره الامريكيه
الان اصبحت تعي بان هذا الهجوم هو من
المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق التي اعلنت
مسؤوليتها وهل سيغير او يبدل من موقف
الاداره الامريكيه تجاه دعمها لاسرائيل
وهو كما ورد في الخبر العاجل من ان اذا
استمرت الولايات المتحده في دعم اسرائيل
سيكون هناك تصعيد ماذا تفهم من
ذلك كان من الواضح ان اداره بايدن كانت
تحاول ان تضغط على الاسرائيليين من اجل
التوصل ل لاطلاق النار لكن الامر يعتمد
على ما يعنيه هذا الامر لان اعطاء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مساحه كبيره
ل استمرار في
هذه العمليه
العسكريه هي تحاول ان تربط بشكل مباشر
وتحاول ان تضغط على الرئيس بايدن من اجل
ان يزيد من معارضته للعمليه العسكريه في
غزه والتي يبدو وكانها الان كان هذه
العمليه لها نهايه مفتوحه